ces aînés vont mettre un casque de
réalité virtuelle pour la première fois
tout le monde sera plongé dans une scène
de la vie quotidienne
je vous retrouverai ma vie mais je veux
tourner dans un sens mais s'il fallait
qu'ils tombaient marche
j'ai trouvé ça extraordinaire parce
qu'on voit tout l'ensemble de l'action
tous un discret un peu oui quand même
on est là dans jal j'ai déjà averti son
propriétaire que tu revenais pas j'ai
donné ton frigo à nick tandy vendus dont
on est très proche de l'action sanous ça
nous invite à intervenir
on veut sensibiliser ses aînés à des
comportements qu'ils peuvent subir mais
aussi ouvrir les yeux de leur entourage
la jce le sait tellement subtil que
beaucoup de gens le font surtout ce
qu'il faut pour toi la borne tout va
bien la fille qui dit à son père alors
tu vas être nous un couac lcl que son
père va mieux je pourrais savoir le
bien-être de l'eau un petit peu dans sa
poule
déjà qu'ils vont être malveillant ou
maltraitance a nécessairement avoir de
mauvaises intentions dans leur tête
parce que dans leur perception ils font
les bonnes choses
j'ai des gens aussi qui reste muet au
tour qu'ils n'interviennent pas on les
bat trois scénarios qui était le plus
coller possible de la réalité des
personnes âgées donc on voulait qu'elle
se reconnaissent qu'ils conjuguent en
jeu par les micros bergin d'or se trouve
porté exagère un peu pour son attitude
est dégagé par rapport à la réalité
le réalisme de ses histoires en trois
dimensions a suscité des réactions très
émotive
il se fait bien de change on le voit ce
chemin
malheureusement ça se passe dans tous
les milieux comme personnes âgées on n'a
pas qu'ils oublient on a parquet qui
décide pour les autres
gardez la sq a raison ça bien été l'une
des forces qu'on est que la réalité
virtuelle c'est que on peut se déplacer
facilement aller animer notre sorte de
lieu et ce sera même de l'âgisme de ne
pas leur offrir
alors que tous les autres public sont
conviés essayé la réalité virtuelle pour
vivre une expérience autrement
les ateliers 360 sont parrainés par des
chercheurs de l'université de sherbrooke
on souhaite les offrir un peu partout au
québec et pas seulement dans les
résidences pour personnes âgées ici anne
louise despatie radio canada montréal